let's take the look at the
implementation of an optional method
we've got in the content provider anyone
out there who has done work with sqlite
knows that putting a bunch of inserts
into a single transaction is much faster
than inserting them individually bulk
insert allows us to do that the default
implementation just calls insert a bunch
of times but we can wrap it in a
transaction if we implemented ourselves
note that we've only added support for
weather forecast transactions here since
they are the only ones we insert in bulk
we start by calling DVD begin
transaction for each of the content
values passed in we insert and update
the number of records inserted when
we're done we set the transaction to be
successful and then rely on the finally
statement to end the transaction note
that if we do not set the transaction to
be successful the records will not be
committed when we call it ends
transaction